bnp news et on va démarrer ce tp news
par les insolites tout ce qui s'est
passé est insolite ce week-end et
géraldine maillet vous avez un truc
insolite à nous raconter c'est un truc
de ouf
alors non mais vous allez décider quelle
a été la meilleure info car oui voilà
tout confondu l'info la plus insolite du
week-end
un truc de dingue alors où est ce que
vous buvez quand vous sortez non je vois
jamais comme agen 28 mois toi quand tu
sors non ça va là j'ai juste une foi
solide c'est la coupe de jean michel
vernhes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la faute à qui pas mal mais c'est pas
mal
mottaki non c'est la faute à qui la
faute à qui merci je vois pas mal c'est
un plaisir et laurien ticket sortie qui
était ivre mort quelque chose de très
très bien et civiques
il a commandé un hubert ilha grande un
taxi pour rentrer parce que comme ça
voilà il ne mettait pas ça
sa santé en danger et malheureusement il
a fait une commande qui ne correspondait
pas à son adresse et il a fait 500 km il
a promis 300 euros quand il a traversé
tout le new jersey au lieu de rentrer
chez lui tout simplement à new york
c'est fort ça vous est déjà arrivé de
vous tromper comme ça vous je croise
utilise beaucoup cette application et
géolocalisation
oui donc je me suis retrouvé à
disneyland paris alors que j'avais
demandé d'aller dans le xviiie donc
égalé par les parents du club vélo sur
la route dès son retour
c'est bon ça va on passera par paris
enfin solide insolite
oui au zimbabwe un ministère de la santé
avait commandé pour la prévention des
campagnes cas très importante à le fait
de la prévention du sida
un grand nombre de préservatifs est
malheureusement en chine et sans doute
quand deux balles aux reins et
préservatifs chinois était beaucoup trop
petit pour les zimbabwéens
un jour c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est
vrai c'est vrai ça une vraie les
préservatifs chinois qui est importé au
zimbabwe était trop petit ils ont donc
inciter les entreprises locales à se
lancer dans la production de
préservatifs dans le but de mieux
répondre aux besoins de la population
c'est un vrai problème des sans-papiers
1 à huy lé pied les chaussures qui
viennent qui sont importés de ces pays
là sans une pointure en moins que que
nos chats qui demande cet italien quoi
bon alors je vois d'accord merci les
sources qu'on risque rien quand on a des
choses sur elle à un pas son pied
exactement bravo jura dit oui vous en
dit vous allez bien vous entendre toutes
les données et faut juste préciser 14%
de la population du zimbabwe quête
athènes par le sien là ils sont donc
c'est très sérieux évidemment à bien
jouer autant que l'ogc en dha le pays à
côté donc faire demain c'est sérieux
vous vous avez notre solide
alors moi j'ai une info insolite qu'elle
que j'adore parce qu'elle concerne une
dame qui a appelé les pompiers à la
ville près de montpellier un petit bled
et l appeler les pompiers en 10 ans il
ya un léopard qui a tenté de bouffer
tout mes poules
donc ils sont arrivés le gris et le
temps des vous rigolez l'armée regarder
ses léopards c'est un chat alors
effectivement et dans un premier temps
[Applaudissements]
d'abord ça ou alors on ne sait pas si
que d'une femme je me suis dit
maintenant madame à des problèmes de vue
quand même de ce que la tête c'est pas
la même sauf que le chant question
comment ça vanne a le plus grand chef de
rome et 600 heureusement on a une photo
du savannah léopard tacheté tâche là
alors il a tort mais le savannah il fait
40 cm d'eau et c'est un croisement entre
en serval mammifères sauvages d'afrique
à mal et un chat domestique
alors effectivement c'est le plus grand
choix de robes bien si vous voulez en
acheter un sas et pas dans un refuge un
ça coûte entre 2000 et 6000 euros la
nuit ouais quand même
en revanche c'est du nombre d'accords
mes doutes sinon vous allez finir moi la
meilleure nous c'est celle de bach
singainy là sur l'insolite on va passer
tout de suite aux people c'est parti je
vous avais l'info people
ah oui alors est la même au cabinet
quadras elle concerne elton john
oui un grand nom de la chanson et se
connaît et ce qu'il a fait ce week end
justement ce qu'il a fait ce week-end
n'est pas acceptable
il était à las vegas en concert ils
invitent toujours des fans à monter sur
scène
violet il a invité les fans ils sont
venus et y en a un qui a eu le malheur
de toucher d'effleurer les touches de
son piano
le monsieur a fait une crise il est
parti il a dit j'arrête le show est ce
cas alors c'est indigne de riz regarde
merci je mets bien
[Musique]
alors non mais il est un peu relou le
mec la menace est un gros lourdaud banc
toute la chanson l'essai de le toucher
est touché l'épaule
c'est vrai ça va vous dire moi et la
gentillesse de faire venir les fans sur
scène du coeur des fans sur scène chaque
soir au moment où l'on joue saturday
night c'est toujours un moment un moment
délicieux du show celui de rencontrer
les fans leur serrer la main
les abords à mes côtés pendant que je
joue ils ont toujours été très courtois
sachant que nous étions en train
d'interpréter une chanson en direct ce
type était impoli dérangeant il n'avait
aucun respect pour notre spectacle et
donc je le dis ce que je ressentais
avant de quitter la scène jusqu'à ce
qu'il en soit les dires du corps qui est
comparé le rouge normalement ça ça
arrive quand est ce que vous êtes au
contact du public mais c'est où sa liste
socialiste de d'évacuer les gens
discrets sans depuis déminer mission
c'est vraiment que tara vie à cinq
personnes
on l'a pas vue comme vianney oui
viennent et je le dis l'incroyable adore
être brillant talentueux en plus il
s'épanouit tout ce qui fait je trouve
que c'est fabuleux
hélas il était dans la maison de maître
gims ah ouais ils ont chanté ensemble
enfin plus exactement vianney à chanter
et c'est une séquence absolument
délicieuse entre les deux c'était une
déclaration d'amour finalement de mettre
une pièce pour y aller regarder ce riad
à marrakech c'est celui de la star de la
musique urbaine m gibbs vous allez
assister en avant-première à
l'enregistrement de ce qui sera
peut-être l'un des tubes de l'année
[Musique]
on prend des boîtes on y range les gens
confondent jamais jamais l'on ne
comprend toujours avec ses lunettes
noires j'entends les gens se demander
quand est ce que tombe le masque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sannois la dia serait trop occupé à huy
à la maison et pas mal ah oui le dark
dog c'est le prénom de sa femme
ouais c'est le prénom de sa femme merci
ben oui positive et la boue dans le clip
a répondu thonon de bella maintenant
vous répondez ton nom de race avait déjà
été dans la villa de m guinand jamais
jamais jamais vous étiez dehors quand
vous à côté des panneaux d'accord très
bien le cas et ce après il faut savoir
c'est que les chanteurs comme la tribune
ils font beaucoup d'argent et et
chansons avec les amis d'hom évidemment
mais maintenant il faut mouiller
bondoukou dans les boîtes de nuit que ça
pour faire de l'argent comme comme
d'autres people etc
et comme il est très beau il rapporte
très cher sa découpe il rapporte envahi
30 chaque soir après trente mille euros
il fait parfois bendriss ndi niveau 80
90 mille euros par week end ça mal ça va
assez vite
il a une bonne petite info news people
bernard montiel oui alors là moi le show
c'est une info très dérangeante c'est le
grand retour de mamy rock mais alors
l'ami rock c'est la grand-mère
maternelle de laëtitia c'est elle que
gérant des trois sociétés désormais qui
vont gérer la carrière future de johnny
est à dire les droits ou tout le pognon
les maisons et tout çà et là la poster
sur instagram une photo que je trouve je
n'y a pas photo avec qui avec salaf avec
un maman de laëtitia par laetitia après
le mois qui s'appelle fabienne donc
s'appelle françois
[Rires]
c
théâtre des gens quoi franchois steam au
sa mère exacte et donc on les voit
toutes les deux et donc ça ne tirer la
langue
si on peut la voir la faute alors
regardez la photo et comment vous
réagissez à ça c'était là c'était
dernièrement
bah oui c'était dimanche essayé essayé
hier c'était dimanche
alors ça veut dire soit soit je vous
emmerde oui franchement que c'était pour
vous je vous emmerde soit j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] de ce que vous racontez contre
les médisants canton tout ça de toute
façon je trouve que vu le drame que nous
vivons avec cette histoire d'héritage où
tout le monde souffre et que ce soit la
mémoire de johnny ou que ce soit toutes
ces familles qui souffrent de toute
façon c'est pas élégance et vous faire
attention à ne pas mettre le drame qu'on
vit tous vraiment pas ça fait on s'en
fout c'est un drame des familles gilles
et glauque mais en fait on n'est pas
concerné oui mais c'est un drame de
cette famille nous a vraiment touché
c'est la disparue shearling bien sûr
bien sûr et on peut dire restantes sont
tous assez heureux on va pas mentir
vas-y stop surtout non plus voilà oui
c'est pas pourquoi ils ont tiré je suis
scandalisé quand même par saba voilà
parce qu'on voulait pas tirer la langue
que peu importe qu importe la
signification mais moi j'ai vu ça je
suis mal à l'aise franchement va pas
chez elle et pour ça mais moi ça me gêne
parce que moi mais ça le pas comme un
nom mais pendant combien de temps
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui bah non
j'ai demandé juste d'agir pendant
combien de temps tu as ton avis doivent
faire la gueule sur les photos mais
qu'est ce qui choque c'est que quelqu'un
tient la langue jaune folie c'est du
mépris bergeaud ne sais pas qui dans le
contexte c'est une extrêmement mal gré
du barreau côté on va dire ça tu l'as
été l'info la people de bernard montiel
on a une info people
une révélation vous pour vous infos
people oui c'est pamela anderson votre
vie privée des personnes bien sûr ses
arrières mais son avance était ramenée
qu'elle a fait plus en faire la
couverture de playboy 13 fois elle
assure qu'elle est vraiment je les fait
deux fois mais j'ai pas fait la
couverture j'ai fait la quatrième est
alors signé avant de s'occuper des
animaux bac en vain que s'intéressait
beaucoup au chaud là parce qu'elle est
allée plusieurs fois dans la maison de
hugh hefner ne pas croiser les bras
alors elle raconte que la première fois
qu'elle est allée dans la maison de
playboy elle était mal or dans toutes
ses étapes parce qu'elle s'est rendue
compte qu'elle était arrivé en pleine
orgie nom en bas les gens étaient
raisonnablement déshabillé sa part si
une fesse par là on sent oublié mais
parce que la partie ne fait pas donc
savez il y avait une fesse et donc la
falla personnes arrivées dans un instant
et donc voilà et elle est tellement
premier étage et là il était en grappes
et donc on lui fait comprendre que ce
serait bien qu'elle les fasse à parent à
commencer par hugh hefner dont elle a
pris des humeurs et les dix n'ont pas de
salsa et à des parties paraît-il très
très vite c'est le cas chez moi j'ai
rien compris ce qu'elle a raconté est-ce
qu'on peut raconter ma mère faux pas des
gp dans la maison de gentner en fait
c'est une maison qui est vraiment fait
pour pour faire démarrer le manoir et
dont est notamment dans la piscine il ya
des espèces de grottes
ouais il ya des matelas un peu partout
et et quand vous y rentrer déjà rien ne
sortait plus d'un an déjà rien qu'à
l'odeur vous avez pas envie d'y rester
oui c'est juste une question qu'est ce
que tu as été faire dans la maison de
ligue 1 justement j'ai fait un sujet sur
hugh hefner jeu les interviewer merci à
vous jean michel vous n'avez jamais fait
de bonnes choses et de rigoler je pense
que c'est des faits qui étaient très
très agréable armées à paris
on court à tout pour elle et quand il
rentrait marché
[Applaudissements]
y avait il y avait les clés et si les
jeunes dicaprio même cameron diaz tout
le monde d'y aller danser avec la team
phoenix mais oui parce qu'en fait c'est
à l'étagé qu'elle est montée fauconnier
quelques mois sa léthargie se passer des
choses d'accord mais elle dit qu'elle
est partie farouche et et à nous dans
une autre interview dix ans plus tard
dont je me souviens quand je l'avais
interviewé l dumont à mes fils a été
conçue là-bas tellement c'est excitant
donc assez à géométrie variable quand
même craint j'ai déjà perdu gaffney
remet pas ne font pas dans la grotte
muller la sienne ni dans la mienne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]